yeah so a lot of people don't understand
how family courts work and what the
incentives are in family courts people
think of them as you know an objective
judge and this sort of thing
um but the way that family courts are
managed is they prevent you from
presenting contrary evidence that's why
I've never been allowed to select a
psychologist for my son
the course will never allow me to do
that the courts pick the psychologist
who will then present the evidence to
the court right now fortunately I've
been able to record them I've been able
to gather evidence and and actually
prove that they perjured themselves so
they've had to throw out all this
evidence but it's taken a lot of work
and it's cost me a lot of money to do
that right and most people can't do that
so family courts basically work off of
fabricated evidence that's number one
number two there's really no appeal from
family courts so family courts unlike
normal like civil courts or criminal
courts there's almost no appellate
options out of a family court so the
judges operate with no oversight and
just do whatever they want and third and
this is the big one
there are massive Federal programs that
were instituted in the late 1970s that
pay States trillions of dollars to tear
families apart so it's so innocuous when
I tell you be like this is a great
program but like in Texas we get 66
cents on the dollar put into the Texas
treasury for every dollar of child
support that's paid
right so the state is now highly
incentivized to issue the maximum amount
of child support that's why they almost
all divorces got 50 50 prior to the
1980s and there was the skyrocketing of
divorces where one parent loses custody
and that was to maximize title IV
reimbursements to the states in Texas
it's half a billion dollars to the Texas
budget if the the state is profiting off
of Child Support correct and in Most
states the judicial retirement fund is
funded from this money so the more child
support that's issued from the family
courts the larger the judicial
retirement
it's and it's a massive program it's the
size of the largest defense programs so
the incentives are absolutely huge to to
to get people to pay child support
correct even married people to get them
to break up and then have to pay each
other child absolutely absolutely yeah
so because you would think the best
child support would just be 50 50
custody and let people raise their kids
the best child support is to raise your
own kid that's the best child support
but they don't do that most States
actually have laws prohibiting the
courts from doing that Texas has uh has
a family code in which it's assumed to
be in the child's best interest that one
parent get 24 of the time and the reason
24 was chosen precisely is it maximizes
title 4D reimbursement to the state at
24 percent
so it has to do with how the state
calculates child support So Texas has
one of the worst child support systems
in the state it doesn't take into
account the income of both parents and
it doesn't take into account the amount
of time you spend with the child
so there there are fathers out there
with 49 of the time that are paying
maximal child support still wow but it
but again that maximizes the
reimbursement to the state I have a
friend of mine him and his wife came to
an agreement to do 50 50 parenting no
child support because he watches the
kids a lot while she travels for her
work and so it's all it all worked out
and they decided it's just better to do
it this way the state of Texas sent an
attorney
to argue in the case that they should
not be allowed to do 50 50 custody I
read a story about uh some celebrity guy
who had to pay massive child support and
then he and the wife both went to the
court together as friends and said hey
he's no longer working and doesn't have
this money anymore so we we both agree
it should be lower in the court said no
they won't do it because they get they
get a cut they get a huge Kickback yeah
wow now there's an even more evil
program that's related to this title for
e
title 4E pays the states to adopt out
orphans
what do you mean adopt out orphans so
whenever whenever CPS takes a child from
from someone and then adopts them into a
good family they get title IV
reimbursement funds and it's a lot of
money it's like 50k per child the state
gets that money yes it goes into the
state budget and where does it come from
federal government interesting yep
so what will happen in Texas is some
satellite office of CPS will get low on
budget and they'll go and find a white
baby under two years of old years old no
no medical problems from working class
parents who can't afford a lawyer and
then they take the child and adopt it
out and then they get fifty thousand
dollars for their budget that's how they
do it wow there's massive incentives uh
to split up families in this country and
that's why you've had the explosion of
divorce and Rancor so now you have the
majority of children in America are
being raised in fatherless homes did you
we passed 50 it's it's it look they're
uh it sure does seem like there is a
system in place whether intentional or
not to reduce the population
unquestionably that's this is the whole
you know you talk about this you call it
a conspiracy theorist right
um but they're blatant about it they're
absolutely blatant about it but I think
the agenda is not only population
reduction
but also to reduce the political power
of the middle class right if you've
you've been to Europe most of you have
been to Europe I've been to Asia a lot
as well nobody cares about Free Speech
there yeah nobody cares about gun rights
there there's one place in the world
where people care about free speech and
gun rights and that's the American
middle class yep they have to disempower
the American middle class to get rid of
these things and so the best way to do
that is to take fathers out of the homes
yeah well that's that's where you start
breaking Society down that's right
destroy the family unit 100 I mean
there's also definitely marriage
disincentives I blame Reagan
no fault divorce but there's also all of
these uh there's tax breaks for you if
you're a single parent and then if
you're married you don't get those tax
breaks that's right wow and it's a lot
easier to get on to state sponsored
health insurance programs unless there's
two of you if there's if if you're
married it's harder to get on them
because you automatically make a little
bit more money yeah in Texas
yeah and you can't get on the states the
state plan there was something about
this I I learned earlier uh that in
Texas I believe it was you need both
parents to consent to some sort of
transgender surgery for a child but then
your wife or your ex-wife took the kid
out of the state in order to bypass
Texas state law so at that point you
would think Texas would be like hey hell
no that we're going to the federal
government come on step in you can't you
can't just
leave our state and then break our law
against the will of one of our state
citizens I would think that that would
be the case yes
um so
um my case has been carefully reverse
engineered by leftist lawyers it's very
clear
to Pro to prevent me from taking a
federal course of action
um what they did was my since my judge
issued an order allowing her to move to
California
it's very difficult for me to go into
federal court and challenge a local
judge's ruling
there's something called The Domestic
Relations exception in family court in
federal court a lot of people don't know
this but the federal court just has a
rule they don't take family court cases
they just don't take them
what like I told you there's no appeal
out of Family Court you're doomed
whatever the judge says goes and federal
courts won't take them there's a very
narrow exception to that on civil rights
grounds which I might be able to pull
off what would that be
so uh there's a there's a really good uh
U.S Supreme Court decision called Troxel
and Troxel establishes 14th Amendment
protections for parenting your children
and all of my judges rulings violate
Troxel
so I'd have to get into a federal court
and uh the Big Challenge in federal
court is you it's very easy to dismiss
Federal cases
under rule 12 of federal as a civil
procedure so I'd have to really build an
airtight case that would survive a
dismissal Challenge and it's the I'm
thinking about that right now a
violation of fourth and 14th Amendment
that's right yeah is uh and what's
interesting is in my 2019 trial that I
that I won I got 50 50 custody no child
support and I got uh 50 50 on all the
conservator rights so she couldn't do
any medical procedures without my
permission I think I remember hearing
about that news but then how did she end
up getting to move to California here's
how it worked so she she retained the
most powerful law firm in the state of
Texas family law firm named Coons Fuller
they're also the largest donor to
political campaigns so Texas has a
loophole that you can buy judges
essentially if as long as you donate to
political campaigns political activity
is protected and law firms cannot be
recused from representing an accord even
if they gave them a lot of money so they
gave my current judge over thirty
thousand dollars
okay thirty thousand bucks so in a
transparently corrupt recusal proceeding
they bought a a judge Emeritus to hear a
recusal hearing and all the judge where
I won the trial her name her name is a
255th District Court
all she did she went on to Facebook on
the official page of the court and said
everyone in my court got a fair trial
which judges are allowed to say things
like that they're allowed to assure the
public that they are performing their
public duty that's not recusable but on
that basis they recused her and then I
wind up in this other court that this
Law Firm gave 30 30
000 to and this judge then
systematically stripped me of all my
parental rights using temporary orders
which is not legal in Texas but I have
no really course of appeal because you
can't in Texas you actually cannot
appeal Family Court decisions you can
only mandamus them you can't actually
appeal them
so using these temporary rulings she
she's systematically and what's
interesting uh when she moves to
California so as a temporary uh right
under yeah and so they want to push they
want to go to final trial now and
establish that as a permanent right
that's the idea well the thing with
California too is California has decided
that they have no obligation to follow
the laws of any other state that's
correct so if if
by some miracle you ended up
um having a Texas Court say that your
sons should come back from California
California would refuse their own law
they won't send them back
um the they they are obligated by law to
give my son gender affirming Health Care
they have to give it to them
and a judge can consent without either
parent consenting a judge can consent
that's a Scott weiner yep state senator
Scott weiner do you do you know if
they've begun any medical procedures
chemical or no because I don't get any
information so she's been there since
end of December and I have no
information on my son at this point it's
just this is a federal we need the
federal government to step in I I the
only issue with the federal government
stepping in is you have the president of
the United States who is in favor of
child sex changes thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time